PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
WITH HER SKIN CONDITION
CLEARING UP, MICHELLE TRIED
TO REGAIN HER CONFIDENCE
AT AN INDUSTRY PARTY
WHILE TIFFANY STARTED
TO LOSE HERS.
SO I'M LOOKING AT THE MAKEUP,
BECAUSE MAKEUP CAN'T
TALK BACK TO ME.
AND BRITTANY WENT
OVER THE TOP.
DRINKS!
IN THE PHOTO SHOOT,
THE MODELS BRAVED THE ELEMENTS,
WHILE LLUVY AND REBECCA
STRUGGLED TO FIND
THEIR SEXINESS.
REBECCA IS SAFE SEX.
BUT AFTER LLUVY'S
THIRD WEAK PHOTO IN A ROW,
THE JUDGES SENT HER HOME.
NINE GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE
ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
THREE PEOPLE HAVE GONE
FROM MY ROOM.
IT SEEMS EMPTY IN THERE NOW.
LLUVY LEFT
A LITTLE NOTE ON MY BED.
YEAH?
I REALLY, REALLY LIKED HER.
IT WAS JUST YOU TWO.
IT'S REALLY HARD.
'CAUSE I MEAN, YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY
MY BEST FRIEND HERE.
TO BE THE LAST TWO THERE,
ALL I CAN REMEMBER THINKING
IS JUST THAT I'M TERRIFIED.
THE JUDGES FEEL MY FACE IS
ALWAYS TOO SWEET AND INNOCENT.
YOU'RE LIKE
A GIRL SCOUT COOKIE.
I REALLY NEED TO WORK ON
STEPPING UP AND BEING SEXY
AND EDGIER,
AND IT'S HARD TO COMPLETELY
CONCENTRATE HERE
WHEN I FEEL LIKE I SHOULD BE
WITH MY FIANCE TODD.
I NEED TO IMPROVE.
I'M REALLY NERVOUS
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE THE PANEL--
THEY'RE LIKE, "OH, THIS GIRL'S
THE, YOU KNOW,
NON-CONFIDENCE SHY GIRL."
THE PHOTOGRAPHER SAID THAT HE
NOTICED YOUR LACK OF CONFIDENCE
RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
20 YEARS OF MY LIFE
IS REALLY HARD TO OVERCOME
IN A FEW WEEKS.
♪♪♪
WE'RE GOING OUT
TO DINNER TONIGHT
TO THE FAMOUS RESTAURANT DOLCE,
WHICH ASHTON KUTCHER OWNS.
WOW.
I LIKE THIS. THIS IS SIMPLE.
I GREW UP IN, LIKE, THE HOOD,
SO THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE
IS TOTALLY DIFFERENT
FROM ANYTHING I'VE EVER BEEN
IN MY WHOLE LIFE.
WE HAVE THE TUNA TARTARE,
AND THEN WE HAVE CALAMARI.
FRIED CALAMARI.
OKAY,
I'M GOING TO TRY SOMETHING.
KAHLEN, WHAT IS THIS?
THAT'S TUNA TARTARE.
IT'S RAW.
KAHLEN, RAW WHAT, EXACTLY?
IT'S TUNA.
I'M NOT USED TO
EATING RAW STUFF, YOU KNOW?
JUST HAVING IT COOKED
OR BURNT OR SOMETHIN'.
OKAY, THAT WAS
LOOKING BACK AT ME.
I JOKE A LOT, I LAUGH IT OFF,
BUT I'M JUST
A FISH OUT OF WATER.
YES, SWEETHEART.
JUICE?
WHERE'D THIS GIRL COME FROM?
♪♪♪
COME ON, GUYS, TYRA MAIL.
"YOU WALK THE WALK,
BUT CAN YOU TALK THE TALK?
BE READY AT 11 A.M."
TALK THE TALK?
WE CAN SLEEP IN.
I UNDERSTAND THAT PART.
♪♪♪
WE'RE PULLING
UP TO THIS PLACE,
KINDA LIKE, "WHAT IS THIS?"
AND THEN I SEE
THE MASQUERADE FACES
ON THE OUTSIDE,
AND I'M LIKE,
"WE'RE ABOUT TO DO SOME ACTING."
OH, GREAT, YOU KNOW?
BECAUSE I KNOW
I'M NOT AN ACTRESS.
I HAD ONE LINE
IN MY FIFTH GRADE PLAY--
"LET THE JOURNEY BEGIN."
SO I'M ACTUALLY REALLY SCARED
ABOUT THIS ONE.
WELL, WELL, WELL.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
GOOD.
AS MODELS YOU MAY BE
CALLED ON TO BE A SPOKESPERSON
PERHAPS DOING A COMMERCIAL.
SPEECH, PRESENTATION, IMAGE--
YOU'LL BE CALLED ON
TO HAVE A LOT
IN YOUR BAG OF TRICKS.
I DEFINITELY SEE
A CORRELATION BETWEEN
THIS ACTING LESSON AND MODELING.
IT'S ABOUT CONFIDENCE.
IT'S ABOUT DOING
WHATEVER YOU'RE ASKED TO DO
WITH CONVICTION.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT A CLIENT
IS GONNA ASK YOU TO DO.
I'M GOING TO TEACH YOU
A DIALECT--COCKNEY.
(record scratches)
COCKNEY?
I CAN BARELY SPEAK ENGLISH.
BETTY FORKS AND BUTTER.
EVERYBODY?
NOW SAY IT WITHOUT THE "T."
BE-Y.
LIKE
"CHITTY CHITTY BANG BANG" TALK
OR "MARY POPPINS."
IF YOU WAN' A GO...
GO!
JUMP UP.
LARRY WOULD CALL US UP
ONE AT A TIME TO MIMIC WHAT
HE'D ALREADY SPOKEN.
(Cockney accent)
WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
IF YOU WAN' A GO, GO.
I AM DEFINITELY NERVOUS.
I'M FROM MINNESOTA,
AND TO COMPLETELY CHANGE
THE WAY I SPEAK
IS GONNA BE VERY DIFFICULT.
WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
IF YOU WAN' A GO, GO.
YOUR FIRST WORD--
DO IT AGAIN.
WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
YOU SAID "AH DON'T KNOW."
SAY IT AGAIN.
OIDON'T KNOW.
TOO FAR.
IF YOU WAN' A GO, JUST GO.
IF YOU WANNA GO, GO.
WELL, I DON'T KNOW. GO.
WHAT WAS THE LINE?
I DID, LIKE, FOUR YEARS
OF DRAMA, SO I CAN DO THIS.
IF YOU WANT TO GO, JUST GO.
(music stops)
DO IT AGAIN.
IF YOU WANT TO GO, JUST GO.
YEAH, YOU DO
THE AMERICAN QUITE WELL.
WELL, IF YOU WAN' A GO, GO.
IF YOU WAN' A GO, GO.
IF YOU WANNA GO, THEN GO.
(record scratches)
OKAY, THERE ARE
MANY INDICATIONS OF SOUTHERN
IN YOUR SPEECH.
IT'S GONNA BE A BIG HANDICAP.
THE OTHER GIRLS SPEAK
A LITTLE MORE CLEARLY THAN I DO,
AND I KNOW IT.
SO IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME.
LADIES, TAKE THIS SCRIPT HOME
AND BECOME THE CHARACTER.
HER NAME'S SUNNY ROSE.
I WANT TO YOU TO BE SUNNY ROSE.
MEMORIZE IT.
BE READY TOMORROW BECAUSE
YOU WILL BE TESTED ON THIS.
HOMEWORK.
THIS IS JUST
AN ALL DAY CHALLENGE FOR ME.
GET OUTTA HERE.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ALREADY.
♪♪♪
HELLO THERE, GUV'NOR.
LOVELY DAY.
GUV'NOR.
HELLO THERE, GUV'NOR.
LOVELY DAY, LOVELY DAY,
'TISN'T IT?
TONIGHT WE HAVE TO MEMORIZE
ALL THE LINES AND PRETTY MUCH
LIVE UP TO THAT CHARACTER.
WANNA PRACTICE?
NO,
'CAUSE ALL I HAVE SO FAR IS,
"FLOWERS. FLOWERS FOR SALE."
I SAY,
THAT'S IT.
"THE SKY IS SPARKLING BLUE
AND A FAIR DAY.
YOU'D HAVE TROUBLE FINDING--"
WHAT IS YOU
TALKING 'BOUT, GIRL?
I HAVE TO LEARN HOW TO SPEAK
LIKE A GIRL FROM ENGLAND,
AND SHE DOESN'T EVEN
KNOW HOW TO TALK HERSELF, SO...
FLOWERS?
YOU CAN TELL
I'M STILL FROM THE SOUTH.
YOU HEAR MY SOUTH
COMING OUT A LOT, HUH?
YOU CAN'T JUST GIVE UP.
I CANNOT SOUND
LIKE THAT.
(phone rings)
HEY, GRANDMA.
Hello, hello, hello.
MY GRANDMOTHER--
SHE AIN'T GOT NO MONEY,
BUT THE LAST TIME I WAS HERE,
THEY SAID THAT I NEEDED
TWO BATHING SUITS,
SO MY GRANDMOTHER
LET THE LIGHTS GO OFF
SO THAT I COULD COME HERE
AND HAVE A BATHING SUIT.
SHE'S WONDERFUL.
YES, SHE SOUNDS AMAZING.
I NEED MY GRANDMA TO HELP ME
FOCUS IN THIS COMPETITION.
PUT IT LIKE THIS--
I DON'T TALK LIKE NOBODY HERE.
That's fine.
You ain't got to talk
like nobody there.
Just be the best you can be.
THAT'S WHAT'S THE HARD PART.
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO BE
SOMEBODY THAT I'M NOT.
I'M SMILING
BUT I'M CRYING ON THE INSIDE.
But you gon' make it through.
I'm proud of you because
you're sticking it out.
BARELY.
♪♪♪
(Cockney accent) I NEVER.
(normal voice) WE ARE GOING TO
PERFORM A SCRIPT THAT LARRY
HANDED TO US YESTERDAY.
I'M NOT VERY GOOD
AT THIS WHOLE ACTING THING.
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
I HAVE TO OVERCOME
IS TO BE VERSATILE.
(whispering)
I'M FEELING REALLY GOOD;
ABOUT MY CHANCES OF ACTUALLY
WINNING AND DOING GOOD.
FLOWERS FOR SALE. AH.
♪♪♪
WE WALK INSIDE,
AND LARRY'S THERE,
OUR INSTRUCTOR FOR COCKNEY.
TODAY YOU'RE GOING TO BE
TESTED ON WHAT YOU LEARNED
YESTERDAY.
BUT YOU WON'T BE ACTING WITH ME
BUT WITH A SPECIAL GUEST.
HE IS A FORMER TOP MODEL, ACTOR,
STAR OF "SECOND TIME AROUND"
AND "SOUL FOOD" ON TELEVISION--
BORIS KODJOE.
WHAT?! OHH!
HEY.
HEY, BORIS,
HOW YOU DOING, MAN?
BORIS KODJOE IS SO SEXY.
NO, THIS CAN'T BE HAPPENING.
THIS CAN'T BE HAPPENING.
OH! OH, MY GOD,
HE'S SO HOT.
I'M GONNA HAVE A HEART ATTACK.
OHH!
I WATCHED HIM ON MOVIES,
AND, WOW, HE'S HERE.
YOU READY?
IN THE NEXT TEN MINUTES,
TRANSFORM YOURSELVES
WITH MAKEUP AND COSTUME.
LET'S GO.
MAMA'S GONNA PASS OUT.
OH, MY GOD.
I'M GONNA MESS UP
IN FRONT OF HIM, GREAT.
THIS IS CRAZY.
THEY GIVE US A BAG, AND IT'S
FULL OF RAGGEDY OLD CLOTHES
AND WE'RE SUPPOSED TO DO
OUR OWN MAKEUP, AND WE HAVE TO,
LIKE, MAKE IT LOOK LIKE
WE DON'T HAVE A TOOTH.
MY MIND IS JUST GOING CRAZY.
I DON'T KNOW
IF I CAN REALLY CAPTURE THIS
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT PERSON.
(muttering)
I'M EXTREMELY NERVOUS,
AND I DON'T KNOW MY LINES.
I'M GONNA MAKE A COMPLETE
AND UTTER FOOL OF MYSELF.
I'M GOING IN THERE TODAY.
I'M GONNA DO THE BEST I CAN,
BUT NOW I'M KINDA HAVING DOUBTS.
I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS.
BRITTANY, YOU'RE FIRST.
FLOWERS FOR SALE,
FLOWERS FOR SALE.
HELLO THERE, GUV'NOR.
LOVELY DAY, 'TISN'T IT?
I HAVEN'T NOTICED.
HAVEN'T NOTICED?
THE SUN'S A-SHINING.
THE SKY'S A SPARKING BLUE.
'TIS A BETTER DAY THAN THIS.
AND TO WHAT MAY I ASK
DO WE ATTRIBUTE
THIS POSITIVE SUNNY ATTITUDE?
IT'S JUST WHO I AM.
WELL, I'M SUNNY ROSE,
I AM, I AM.
I'M SUNNY ROSE, I AM.
SUNNY ROSE.
WELL, YOU'RE IN
THE WRONG BUSINESS, SUNNY.
YOU'RE A NATURAL BORN
PERFORMER.
ARE YOU TRYIN' TO
RUN ME UP THE APPLES AND PEARS?
I DON'T THINK SO.
'CAUSE I'VE KNOWN
PLENTY OF BLOKES.
SICK OF
THE TROUBLE AND STRIFE.
OKAY, HOLD ON.
SICK OF THE TROUBLE
AND STRIFE.
EXCUSE ME?
TELLING PORKY PIES TO TRY
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF SOME YOUNG...
UNEXPECTED LASS.
HOLD ON.
TELLING PORKY PIES...
I DON'T KNOW.
SORRY. HOLD ON.
LIES, WIVES, PORKY PIES.
NEXT.
HELLO THERE, GUV'NOR.
LOVERLY DAY,
'TISN'T IT?
I'M ALWAYS WORKING VERY HARD
ON PUTTING FORTH
MY BEST EFFORT.
I FEEL REALLY GOOD
ABOUT THIS CHALLENGE.
ROSE FOR A BEAUTIFUL ROSE.
CALL ME.
A REAL LIVE FASHION MODEL.
THANK YOU.
MICHELLE, YOU'RE ON.
WHOO.
MICHELLE HAS FOUR YEARS
OF THEATER.
I THINK SHE'S
MY TOUGHEST COMPETITION HERE.
OH, WELL,
HELLO THERE, GOVERNOR.
LOVELY DAY,
LOVELY DAY, 'TISN'T IT?
I HAVEN'T NOTICED.
HAVEN'T NOTICED?
HAVEN'T NOTICED?!
THE OTHER GIRLS-- THEY'VE BEEN
WINNING CHALLENGES,
AND IT'S LIKE,
FINALLY THIS IS SOMETHING THAT,
YOU KNOW, I COULD POSSIBLY WIN.
A REAL LIVE
FASHION MODEL.
WELL, I NEVER.
I ROCKED IT.
I JUST FELT AMAZING.
YOU MAY BEGIN.
(Southern drawl)
I SAY FLOWERS.
FLOWERS FOR SALE.
WELL, HELLO THERE, GUV'NOR.
TIFFANY WAS A SOUTHERN GIRL
FROM A PLANTATION DOWN
IN ALABAMA.
WELL, THE SUN'S SHINING,
THE SKY'S SPARKLING BLUE.
SHE WAS IN HER OWN MOVIE.
TROUBLE AND STRIFE?
TRYING TO--
I'M SITTING THERE LOOKIN' AT
BORIS, HE'S LOOKING AT ME,
I'M LOOKIN' AT HIM, LIKE,
(whispers) HEY, BORIS,
GO WITH THE NEXT LINE.
(normal voice) HE DIDN'T TRY
TO HELP ME OUT A LITTLE BIT.
HE KEPT LOOKING AT ME.
I'M REALLY EMBARRASSED.
BUT YOU KNOW,
I DON'T CARE IF
I MISSED THE TEST.
(wheezing)
SO I JUST LAUGHED IT OFF.
WELCOME BACK.
GREAT JOB, GUYS.
BRITTANY.
RIGHT HERE.
I LOVED YOUR ACCENT.
THANK YOU.
TATIANA.
DON'T GET THROWN BY TRYING
TO LOOK FOR THE WORDS AND FOR
THE LINES THAT YOU MISSED.
KAHLEN.
YEAH, KAHLEN,
I THINK HALF OF YOUR SCENE
WOULD HAVE BEEN BLEEPED OUT
BECAUSE YOU SWORE AND CURSED.
CHRISTINA. CHRISTINA SKIPPED
A COUPLE OF PAGES.
YEAH.
MICHELLE, YOU DIDN'T
HAVE ANY EYE CONTACT.
REBECCA.
WOULD LIKED TO HAVE SEEN
MORE PASSION, COMMITMENT.
I TOOK HIS CRITICISM
AND JUST, YOU KNOW,
NODDED MY HEAD,
BUT I'M VERY DISAPPOINTED.
NAIMA, GOOD ACCENT.
FLIRTATIOUS.
IT'S VERY GOOD.
KEENYAH--PLAYING, FLIRTING,
EYE CONTACT. ALL GOOD.
TIFFANY.
UM... LOVED THE HAT.
(record scratches)
SO NOW WE'RE
GONNA ANNOUNCE THE WINNER.
NOW THE WINNER GETS--
LET'S HAVE
THAT FANFARE HAND.
$10,000 IN DIAMONDS
TO SHARE WITH TWO FRIENDS.
NO, THIS HAS TO BE A JOKE.
IT'S NOT A JOKE.
$10,000 WORTH OF DIAMONDS.
DID YOU HEAR ME?
I SAID 10.
AND NOW LET US
ANNOUNCE THE WINNER.
(hums fanfare)
NAIMA!
NAIMA, COME UP HERE.
YAY.
THANK YOU.
NOW YOU HAVE TO
ANNOUNCE YOUR TWO FRIENDS.
MICHELLE.
GIVE HER A HAND.
I MAY HAVE BEEN COME
SECOND BEST, BUT...
♪ I'M GETTIN' DIAMONDS ♪♪
AND TATIANA.
WHAT?!
AIN'T THAT BUT A BITCH?!
TATIANA--SHE GOT THE NERVE
TO GET SOME DIAMONDS.
I'M UPSET.
LATER, TIFFANY.
TAKE CARE. GOOD LUCK.
OW.
COCKNEY--IT'S CRAZY.
GHETTO ENGLISH.
WHITEGHETTO.
WE'RE ALL JUST, LIKE, SITTING
AROUND, LOUNGING AND EVERYTHING,
TALKING ABOUT COCKNEY ENGLISH,
COCKNEY ENGLISH.
WHAT IS IT?
WHITE GHETTO ENGLISH.
EVERYBODY ALWAYS
TALKS ABOUT THE GHETTO
LIKE THAT'S SOMETHING BAD,
LIKE ONLY BAD PEOPLE COME
FROM THE GHETTO.
THERE ARE INTELLIGENT PEOPLE
IN THE GHETTO.
MY MOM'S INTELLIGENT,
MY GRANDMA
IS VERY INTELLIGENT.
I'M GHETTO 'CAUSE PROBABLY
I CHOSE TO BE GHETTO, AND THAT'S
JUST--THAT'S WHO I AM.
A LOT OF PEOPLE'S
INTERPRETATION OF BEING GHETTO
IS SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
PROFESSIONAL.
EVERYBODY--
SO THAT'S WHY
I DON'T TALK LIKE
THE OTHER GIRLS WHO LIVE
IN COMPTON, LIKE...
IT'S CRAZY.
I'M JUST READY TO GO HOME.
I JUST FELT
SO UPSET AT MYSELF,
THAT I'VE BEEN TRYING TO CHANGE
ALL THESE DIFFERENT THINGS
ABOUT ME, AND I'M UNHAPPY.
MAYBE I CAN'T BE THIS PERSON
THAT--THIS MODEL GIRL,
AND MAYBE THAT'S NOT WHO I AM.
♪♪♪
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE
THE FRONT SEAT, NAIMA?
BYE, GIRLS.
ME, NAIMA AND MICHELLE
COME UP TO THIS
REALLY, REALLY, OLD BANK
AND GO DOWN INTO THE BASEMENT.
HELLO, LADIES, WELCOME.
I'M DAN KOHANARIEH,
THE C.E.O. OF KRAIKO DIAMONDS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT YOU
WITH DIAMOND JEWELRY.
THERE'S THIS HUGE VAULT
BEHIND THEM WITH THIS GIANT LOCK
LIKE ON THE MOVIES
AND EVERYTHING.
AND IT'S LIKE,
IS THIS REALLY HAPPENING?
THANK YOU.
THEY STARTED PULLING OUT
THE DIAMONDS.
I WAS LIKE, "OH, MY GOD."
NAIMA...
YOU HAVE THE BEST SELECTION.
I LOVE THE YELLOW DIAMOND.
YOU LOVE
THE YELLOW DIAMOND.
WONDERFUL.
I LIKE THE NECKLACE
THAT WAS A YELLOW DIAMOND.
IT WAS UNIQUE.
IT WAS INDIVIDUAL, LIKE ME.
MICHELLE?
UM... I THINK THIS ONE.
I WOULD SAY GO
WITH THAT ONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
CONGRATULATIONS.
TATIANA.
YOU'RE LOOKING GREAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GREAT. YOU'RE WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I HOPE YOU'RE HAPPY
WITH YOUR CHOICES.
IT'S AMAZING.
GORGEOUS.
(phone rings)
HI, HONEY.
Hi.
I'M MAKING MYSELF SICK,
EVEN LIKE SICK TO MY STOMACH
WITH NERVOUSNESS
IN THIS COMPETITION.
IT'S LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE IS
KINDA TAKING ITS TOIL, YOU KNOW?
It's getting stressful
is what you're saying?
YEAH.
IT'S A VERY HARD
AND LONG STRUGGLE FOR ME.
I KNOW WHAT
I NEED TO WORK ON HERE,
BUT ALL I CAN DO IS JUST PRAY.
Just remember,
you're really strong, you know?
You've been through a lot
already.
TYRA MAIL!
WHO'S NOT HERE?
TIFFANY'S ON THE COUCH.
OH.
"TOP MODELS ARE NEVER CHICKEN.
TOMORROW THE FEATHERS WILL FLY.
BE READY
AT 8:00 IN THE MORNING."
CHICKEN.
TOP MODELS ARE...
JUMPING OUT OF A PLANE.
(gasps)
I NEVER UNDERSTAND
TYRA MAILS,
SO I'M JUST TIRED OF GUESSING.
I JUST WANT TO
READ THIS AGAIN.
THE JUDGES FEEL
THEY HAVE SEEN IMPROVEMENTS
IN EVERYONE ELSE'S PHOTOS,
AND I GUESS IN MINE,
THEY HAVEN'T,
SO I NEED TO NAIL THIS.
I NEED TO NAIL THIS.
I HAVE TO.
I DON'T WANNA GO HOME.
(sighs)
TYRA MAIL SAYS,
"TOP MODELS CAN'T BE CHICKEN.
GET READY FOR THE FEATHERS
TO FLY."
I THINK TODAY'S SHOOT'S
GONNA BE MORE OF A SCARY,
RISK-TAKING,
DANGEROUS SITUATION,
SEE HOW WE CAN HANDLE THAT.
I'M GONNA GIVE IT ALL I'VE GOT,
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO GO HOME.
WE WERE DRIVING UP
IN THE HILLS, AND I'M LIKE,
OH, NO, THEY'RE GONNA MAKE US
JUMP OFF OF SOMETHING.
GOOD MORNING.
LOOK, WE'RE OUT HERE
WITH THIS AMAZING VIEW
UP IN THE HILLS OF HOLLYWOOD,
AND I KNOW
YOU GUYS ARE PROBABLY WONDERING
WHAT ARE WE DOING TODAY?
TODAY WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA
ALLOW YOU GIRLS
TO GET OUT SOME AGGRESSION
AND MAYBE A LITTLE
SEXUAL FRUSTRATION.
OH, GOD.
SO TODAY'S SHOOT--
WE GOT A LITTLE SOMEONE
TO WORK WITH YOU.
RIB, CAN YOU COME ON
OUT HERE FOR ME?
YES!
HIS NAME IS RIB.
RIB IS A TOP MODEL.
OH, JEEZ.
WHAT ARE
WE GOING TO DO TODAY?
THESE ARE THE GIRLS,
AND THIS IS WHAT
RIB IS WEARING.
KAHLEN, IT'S OKAY.
YOU CAN TAKE IT OFF.
THIS IS PG.
I NEVER
REALLY HAD A BOYFRIEND.
I'M STILL, LIKE,
IN THE FIFTH GRADE MODE
WHERE I GET REALLY BEET RED,
AND I'M A LITTLE FREAKED OUT
BY THIS ONE.
SO THIS IS WHAT
HE'S WEARING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK
YOU GIRLS ARE WEARING?
NOT MUCH OF ANYTHING.
YOU GIRLS ARE WEARING SOME
AMAZING BRAS FROM WONDERBRA.
YOU GIRLS ARE HAVING SOME FUN,
HANGING OUT WITH YOUR BOYFRIEND,
SO THIS WHOLE SITUATION
HAS TO BE BELIEVABLE.
I'M NOT EXCITED
LIKE SOME OF THE GIRLS HERE.
I'M ENGAGED AND ABOUT TO BE
MARRIED WHEN I GET HOME,
SO IT'S A LITTLE AWKWARD.
TODAY'S PHOTOGRAPHER
IS KWAKU.
HEY, GUYS.
HOW YOU DOING?
WHAT'S GOING ON?
SO LET'S GO.
GOLD!
LOOK AT THAT.
I'M READY.
I'M JUST GONNA TRY TO
GO INTO THIS SHOOT
AND USE EVERYTHING.
I'M DEFINITELY GONNA HAVE
THE SEX APPEAL
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR.
WHAT ARE WE SELLING?
THE BRA. OKAY.
SOUNDS GREAT.
REMEMBER, THE BRA.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE BRA.
(squealing)
LOVE THAT, BRITTANY.
LOVE THAT.
HIT HIM, HIT HIM!
I KNOW THERE WAS
A LOT GOING ON THERE
WITH THE FEATHERS, THE WIND,
THE FAN, BUT, YOU KNOW,
AS A GOOD TOP MODEL,
YOU'RE AWARE OF
EVERYTHING.
BEAUTIFUL, GUYS.
BEAUTIFUL.
BRITTANY WAS AMAZING.
THERE WE GO.
THAT'S IT.
CHIN UP, TATIANA.
TURN YOUR BODY
A LITTLE BIT TOWARDS ME.
TATIANA WAS
TOTALLY UNINHIBITED WITH RIB.
GOTTA SEE THE BRA.
BUT SHE WASN'T
AWARE OF THE BRA.
TATIANA, YOU'RE DONE.
SHE LOOKED SO BEAUTIFUL.
DID YOU HAVE FUN?
I HAD SO MUCH FUN.
DID YOU FEEL
ANY CHEMISTRY?
NO.
NO? SHE DID.
I'M THINKING, OH, JEEZ,
I DON'T WANT TO DO THIS.
GET ME OUTTA HERE.
IT SCARED THE BEJ...
OUT OF ME.
KEENYAH, LOOK AT HIM.
RELAX, RELAX.
COME ON, KEENYAH,
I KNOW YOU GOT MORE FIRE
THAN THAT.
FEEL THE MOMENT.
GET UP A LITTLE BIT.
UP A LITTLE BIT.
FEEL THAT MOMENT
HE'S GIVING YOU.
KEENYAH--SHE DIDN'T FIND
THAT CONNECTION.
SHE JUST COULDN'T DO IT.
LET'S WRAP THAT UP.
(blows)
GOING INTO THE PHOTO SHOOTS,
I'M REALLY NERVOUS
AND I'M NOT CONFIDENT
WITH HOW IT MIGHT TURN OUT,
AND I DON'T WANT
THE REASON FOR ME GOING HOME
BEING MY CONFIDENCE.
'CAUSE I CAN ALREADY FEEL
THE HEART GOING.
OH, MY GOD.
THAT'S GOOD, THOUGH.
IT'S LIKE
THE FIRST TIME.
DON'T BE AFRAID OF HIM!
LET HIM HOLD YOU.
PUSH ON HIM, STRUGGLE BACK
AND FORTH LIKE THIS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LET'S GO, GUYS.
KAHLEN FELT
A LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE IN THAT
SORT OF INTIMATE SETTING.
LOOK AT YOUR BOYFRIEND!
IT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING SHE NEEDS TO WORK ON,
BECAUSE AS A MODEL, YOU NEED TO
WORK WITH A PARTNER OFTEN.
TIFFANY?
COME ON, GIRL.
GOTTA GET INTO THIS.
NO PLAYING,
NO TIME TO BE SHY TODAY.
YOU GOTTA BELIEVE IT.
ACTORS GOT
TO MAKE THIS REAL.
I REALLY, REALLY WANNA
MAKE IT BELIEVABLE.
BRING YOUR CHIN UP, TIFFANY!
BRING YOUR CHIN UP!
SHOW THAT BRA!
I JUST
REALLY FELT SO SILLY.
MY MIND HAS SHUT OFF
AND EVERYTHING.
SMILE.
LAUGH AT HIM!
I CAN'T GET
INTO CHARACTER.
PUT YOUR HAIR UP.
YOU GOT A FEATHER IN THE EYE.
LOOK AT HIM IN HIS EYE.
COME ON, TIFFANY.
COME ON, GIRL, LAUGH!
TIFFANY
DID NOT LET GO
AND WOULD NOT LET HIM IN.
IT WAS HARDER
THAN I THOUGHT.
IF I DON'T HAVE A GOOD PHOTO,
THEY MAY SEND ME HOME,
BUT I CAN'T CHANGE THAT.
HERE WE GO, GUYS.
CHRISTINA, ACT UP!
NICE.
SEXY SMILE!
ALL RIGHT.
VERY HOT.
KEEP GIGGLING.
HOLD THAT PILLOW, GIRL.
HOLD THAT PILLOW.
COME ON!
IT WAS REALLY HARD TO KEEP
MY MIND ON THIS PHOTO SHOOT
WHEN I'M CHOKING ON FEATHERS.
OH!
I THINK
WE ALL GOT HAIRBALLS.
YES! YES, WE DO!
CLEAVAGE.
GIVE THEM CLEAVAGE.
THE ANXIETY HAS JUST BEEN
BUILDING AND BUILDING
ALL DAY LONG.
YOU GUYS LOOK
SEXY TOGETHER. WOW!
ALL I CAN THINK OF
IS JUST GET THE SHOT,
AND THEN I'M OUT OF THERE.
HIT HIM!
LOOK AT HIM!
WHEN I WAS IN THERE,
I JUST PUT TODD'S HEAD
ON THIS GUY'S BODY
AND JUST LET LOOSE A LITTLE BIT.
OH, THERE YOU GO.
I THOUGHT
I COULD HANDLE IT.
BUT IT'S SO MUCH MORE
UNCOMFORTABLE AND EMOTION-FILLED
THAN YOU THINK IT IS.
SMILE! SMILE, GIRL!
HAIR, HAIR.
REBECCA--SHE LOST IT.
I FELT THAT SHE COULD HAVE BEEN
A LITTLE BIT MORE AGGRESSIVE.
SHE DID NOT ACT
THE PART FOR ME.
WHO'S NEXT?
♪ MICHELLE ♪♪
YOU KNOW WHAT SHE DOES,
RIGHT?
SHE'S A WRESTLER CHICK.
NO WAY.
YES, SERIOUSLY.
(bell dings)
OH, MICHELLE,
YOU'RE GOOD, GIRL.
GRAB HIM BY THE BACK
OF HIS HAIR IF YOU WANT.
GO.
YES, GREAT!
DO IT AGAIN!
MICHELLE IS A STRONG GIRL,
AND SHE'S PINNING ME DOWN.
IF IT WAS A WRESTLING MATCH,
SHE PROBABLY WOULD HAVE WON.
LET'S DO THAT AGAIN.
GOT IT.
YEP. THANK YOU.
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL.
I WONDER
WHAT IT SAYS.
"TOMORROW MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY EIGHT OF YOU WILL CONTINUE
ON IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
KEENYAH,
YOU ARE EXCLUDED."
THANK YOU.
OH, GOSH.
ELIMINATION
IS GONNA BE TONIGHT.
OOH, I DON'T WANT TO
THINK ABOUT IT.
I DON'T KNOW
IF I HAVE A PICTURE THE JUDGES
ARE GONNA BE HAPPY WITH.
I'VE NEVER WALKED AWAY
FROM ANY PHOTO SHOOT GOING,
"YES, I NAILED IT."
(hair scraping brush)
I REALLY THINK IT MIGHT
BE ME THAT'S GOING HOME
BECAUSE I'M NOT VERY CONFIDENT
WITH MY PHOTO SHOOT.
DON'T BE AFRAID OF HIM.
AND IT'S REALLY SCARY.
MY GRANDMA KEPT TELLING ME,
"YOU ARE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
I'M LIKE,
"GRANDMA, I'M GHETTO.
COME ON."
I DON'T
REALLY FIT IN HERE.
A LOT OF IT IS FEAR
OF SOMETHING THAT'S DIFFERENT--
FEAR OF SOMETHING THAT
YOU'RE NOT, LIKE, USED TO.
YOU'RE GETTING JUDGED
ON THE TRANSFORMATION
IN YOUR PHOTOS AND WITH
WHO YOU ARE AS A PERSON.
OHH.
REMEMBER,
YOU'VE BEEN PICKED.
YOU'RE WANTED HERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
NOW IT'S TIME
TO MAKE OUR SIXTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER TOWARDS
DETERMINING WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOU GUYS KNOW WE HAVE
SOME FABULOUS PRIZES, RIGHT?
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH TOP INTERNATIONAL
MANAGEMENT COMPANY FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE SHOT
BY WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMONE,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
NOW YOU'VE COME TO KNOW
AND LOVE AND HATE US JUDGES.
RIGHT, JANICE?
JANICE IS ONE OF
THE WORLD'S FIRST SUPERMODELS.
THE WORLD'S FIRST SUPERMODEL.
WORK IT OUT.
NIGEL BARKER,
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
NOLE MARIN,
PROMINENT FASHION EDITOR
AND STYLIST,
AND OUR SPECIAL GUEST JUDGE
BORIS KODJOE,
WHO I USED TO MODEL WITH
WAY BACK IN THE DAY.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
WE'RE GONNA SEND YOU
ON A MOCK SPECIAL ASSIGNMENT.
YOU'RE GONNA BE A SPECIAL
GUEST HOST FOR A.N.T.M.-TV.
AND, MICHELLE, YOU'RE FIRST.
SO, MICHELLE, YOU'LL BE
GUEST HOSTING
AND COMMENTATING
USING THE SKILLS YOU LEARNED
DURING THIS WEEK'S TEACH.
YOU MUST GIVE A STATUS REPORT
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH PARIS FASHION WEEK.
BUT WHAT'S DIFFERENT TODAY IS
INSTEAD OF READING
FROM A SCRIPT,
YOU'RE GONNA BE READING COLD
ON A PROMPTER.
MAKE IT FUN.
ALL RIGHTY. I'M READY.
OKAY.
HI, MICHELLE HERE
AT THE A.N.T.M.-TV.
IT'S FASHION WEEK IN PARIS,
AND TELECOLOR IS THE NAME
OF THE GAME.
CAN YOU SAY...
MAGENTA?
MAGNETA?
MAGEN-TA?
CHARTREUSE.
CHAR... TREE?
I DON'T KNOW THAT WORD.
VIVID VIBRANT COLORS
AREN'T THE ONLY STORY HERE.
CHRISTIAN LACROIX.
CHRISTIAN LOX-ROY.
CHRISTINA LECR...
HMM.
AND...
AND HERMES.
HERMIS.
HERMS.
AND HERMIS ARE ALL MAKING
A BIG... SPLISH SPLASH.
LOOKS TO THE LEFT. OH.
WOW!
THERE'S TIFFANY,
TOP MODEL.
GISELE BUND-EN.
KAROLINA KURKOVA.
PORVOZA?
KUR-- KOV--
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
OH, GOSH.
SO I'M GONNA HANG OUT
WITH THE CHICK.
WITH THE CLICK--OR... YEAH.
THE CHICK
TO GET THAT LOOK FRANCHES.
FRAGOTE.
AU REVOIR.
AR-REVOR.
AU-REVOR.
HI, I'M TIFFANY.
IT'S FASHION WEEK IN PARIS.
AND, UM, TECHNICOLOR
IS THE NAME OF THE GAME.
CAN YOU--I CAN'T DO THIS.
YES, YOU CAN.
YOU GO ON.
I CAN'T.
WHY?
BREATHE AND GO THROUGH IT.
JUST TRY TO
GO THROUGH IT.
TIFFANY, THE OTHER GIRLS
DID NOT KNOW THESE WORDS.
THEY GOOFED THE WORDS.
GO THROUGH IT.
JUST HAVE FUN WITH IT.
USE YOUR PERSONALITY.
BE YOU.
I DON'T KNOW.
YOU WANT TO
GO HOME?
IF YOU DON'T DO THIS,
YOU'RE GONNA GO HOME.
HI, I'M TIFFANY.
IT'S FASHION WEEK
IN PARIS.
CAN YOU--
I CAN'T DO THIS.
YES, YOU CAN. GO ON.
I CAN'T.
WHY?
IF YOU DON'T DO THIS,
YOU'RE GONNA GO HOME.
TIFFANY, THE OTHER GIRLS
DID NOT KNOW THESE WORDS.
MAGNETA?
CHAR... TREE?
WHO CARES?
THEY'RE JUST WORDS.
HAVE FUN.
HI, I'M TIFFANY
HERE WITH AMT--A.N.T.M.-TV.
IT'S FASHION WEEK IN PARIS.
CAN YOU SAY MAGNETIC?
JUST KEEP GOING.
CHARISMATIC, SOLID GOLD
AND SHOCKING PINK.
WOW! TIPSY TOP MODELS.
OH, MY GOD,
THIS IS HARD.
OKAY, TIPSY TOP MODELS,
TIFFANY, KEENYAH
AND SOME OTHER GIRLS
HANGING WITH TYRA HERSELF.
BACK TO YOU, TYRA.
OH, MY GOD.
(sighs) THIS IS HUMILIATING.
MORE AND MORE EACH WEEK.
ALL RIGHT, MICHELLE.
COME ON FORWARD.
SO YOU WERE
A FASHION CORRESPONDENT.
THE NAME IS HERMES.
HERMIS.
HERMS.
AND...
HELLO!
EVERYBODY,
YOU'VE GOT TO LEARN
THE PEOPLE IN THE BUSINESS.
NONE OF YOU GIRLS CAN READ,
SORRY.
ALL RIGHT, MICHELLE,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO MODEL BRAS
AND YOU HAD A PILLOW FIGHT.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
WORK IT OUT, GIRLFRIEND.
THAT IS FABULOUS.
YOU HAVE A CERTAIN SOMETHING
THAT REALLY CONNECTS
TO THE CAMERA.
BRITTANY.
I THINK BRITTANY HAD
THE BEST ENERGY OF THEM ALL.
I FEEL LIKE TO BE
ANY TYPE OF CORRESPONDENT,
YOU HAVE TO BE BIG.
YOU HAVE TO BE OUT THERE,
AND ALL THE BUTCHERY
AND ALL THE MESSING UP
OF THE WORDS,
BECAUSE
YOU WERE SUCH A FOOL...
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
IT JUST MADE THE PERSON
AT HOME GOING, "SHE'S CRAZY,
BUT I LIKE HER."
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
OH! BEST ONE YET,
I THINK.
BEST ONE!
IT'S SEXY AS HELL,
BUT IT'S STILL NOT HO-ISH.
SLAM DUNK ON THE FACE,
GIRL.
REBECCA, YOU HAD TO BE
A NEWS CORRESPONDENT.
YOU WERE BORING.
YOUR EYES DIDN'T CONNECT.
I THOUGHT
YOUR ENERGY WAS DEAD.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOU DIDN'T
FIND THE LIGHT.
A MODEL HAS TO BE ABLE
TO BATHE IN THE LIGHT.
I THINK
YOUR BODY LOOKS GREAT.
YOU THINK
THE BODY LOOKS GREAT?
YEAH, I THINK SHE LOOKS
NICE AND SLIM.
THE LOWER HALF--
IT LOOKS COMPLETELY DISTORTED.
KEENYAH.
I THINK YOU DEFINITELY
NEED TO STUDY
YOUR FASHION DICTIONARY.
CHRISTIAN LACROH.
THE DESIGNERS--
YOU SLAUGHTERED THEM.
THIS IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
BREASTS LOOKS NICE,
FACE LOOKS OUT OF PICTURE.
THE PHOTOGRAPHER
KEPT TELLING ME
TO SHOW OFF MORE OF THE BRA.
BUT YOU STILL HAVE TO
FIND THE LIGHT.
YOU GOTTA GO, NOT...
YOU GOTTA CHEAT.
KAHLEN.
KAHLEN, WHERE DID THAT...
(deep voice) MAN COME FROM?
(deep voice)
IT'S FASHION WEEK IN PARIS.
EVEN THOUGH YOU SOUNDED
LIKE THE WEATHERMAN,
YOU HAD GOOD SPIRIT
AND YOU FOUGHT THROUGH IT.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
THE HAIR.
IT LOOKS LIKE
"VALLEY OF THE DOLLS"
GOT ELECTROCUTED.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU STUCK
YOUR FINGER IN A LIGHT SOCKET.
AND HE'S LOOKING
AT YOUR BREASTS LIKE,
"OOH, YEAH, BABY."
IN YOUR PHOTO SHOOT,
JAY SAID THAT YOU WERE SHY
SHOOTING WITH RIB,
AND THAT IT WAS NEW TO YOU,
THAT YOU NEVER HAD
A BOYFRIEND.
YOU HAVEN'T
HAD A BOYFRIEND?
I PLEAD THE FIFTH.
TIFFANY.
EVERY NOW AND THEN
I FALL APART,
AND YOU FELL APART.
YOU HAD A DEFEATIST ATTITUDE
WHEN YOU WALKED OUT.
YOU SAID EVERY WEEK
IT JUST GETS WORSE AND WORSE.
THIS IS HUMILIATING.
MORE AND MORE EACH WEEK.
I SAID EVERY WEEK
I HUMILIATE MYSELF WEEKLY.
I KNOW WHAT I SAID.
HANG ON, I'M NOT DONE.
YOU LOOK GREAT.
BUT WITH THAT ATTITUDE,
MISS THING... EEE.
YOU'RE VERY BEAUTIFUL,
SO THERE'S NOTHING
YOU SHOULD HIDE, YOU KNOW?
YOU SHOULD COME OUT
AND BE JUST GLOWING.
I CAN'T SIT HERE AND SAY,
"DO IT. DO IT."
DO YOU WANNA GO HOME?
YOU HAVE TO HEAR THAT
INSIDE OF YOUR HEAD,
BECAUSE IN THE REAL WORLD
PEOPLE ARE GONNA BE LIKE,
"NEXT," AND NOT CARE.
OKAY.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
THE BODY LANGUAGE--
IT'S, LIKE, HALFWAY.
CLEARLY YOU WERE
UNCOMFORTABLE AND YOU DIDN'T
LET GO AND YOU BUILT UP A WALL
BETWEEN YOURSELF AND RIB.
NAIMA.
YOU WERE OVERACTING.
WOW!
THIS SORT OF FAKE CHARACTER
CAME ALONG.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
IS THAT YOU WITH HAIR?
NAIMA HAS HAIR?
YOU WEREN'T TRYING HARD ENOUGH
IN THIS PICTURE.
I GOTTA AGREE.
IT'S ALWAYS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SHOW WHAT YOU GOT,
AND THIS TIME YOU DIDN'T.
I HAVE TO WORK HARDER.
CHRISTINA.
CHRISTINA, TO ME,
YOUR WHOLE READ WAS LIKE
BAD PUBLIC ACCESS TELEVISION.
(laughter)
YEAH, THE WHOLE THING
SOUNDED LIKE
A FOREIGN LANGUAGE TO ME.
SO NEXT TIME
YOU JUST MAKE IT UP.
JUST ROLL WITH IT.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOU DON'T LOOK PRETTY.
HAUGHTY. HAUGHTY.
I LIKE THE ENERGY
BETWEEN YOU GUYS AND I ALSO LIKE
THE FACT THAT IT'S NOT POSED.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST
IS TATIANA.
TATIANA, YOU'RE LACKING
SO ENORMOUSLY IN CONFIDENCE.
YOU DIDN'T KNOW
WHO THE DESIGNERS WERE.
YOU COULDN'T PRONOUNCE
THE DESIGNERS.
CHRISTIAN LOX-ROY.
I FOUND YOUR READ
NONBELIEVABLE.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
OH, GOSH.
EVEN IN THE MIDDLE
OF A PILLOW FIGHT
YOU'RE STILL WORKING
IN FRONT OF A CAMERA.
DO IT, JANICE.
NIGEL'S THE MODEL,
AND THE LIGHT'S UP THERE.
OKAY, WAIT A MINUTE.
THE LIGHT IS UP THERE.
THE LIGHT IS UP THERE!
NOT LOOKING DOWN,
'CAUSE IF I LOOK DOWN,
YOU'RE NOT SELLING YOUR FACE,
WHICH IS SO BEAUTIFUL.
EVERY CLICK OF THE CAMERA IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU TO SHOW
WHAT YOU GOT.
DON'T WASTE THAT OPPORTUNITY.
AU REVOIR, BITCHES.
♪♪♪
BRITTANY.
BRITTANY IS LIKE
A WILD HORSE, AND SHE'S FINALLY
BEGINNING TO TAME HERSELF,
AND THIS PICTURE IS
A PERFECT EXAMPLE--
SEXY, YET NOT TOO HOOCHIE.
TATIANA.
TATIANA IS NOT A WOMAN.
SHE'S A GIRL.
BUT DOESN'T
THE FASHION INDUSTRY LIKE GIRLS?
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
IN PICTURES AND ON THE RUNWAY,
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO CONVEY
SOME SORT OF CONFIDENCE.
NAIMA.
IN THIS SHOT,
SHE LOOKS LIKE DRACULA.
I THINK THIS PICTURE IS GOOD,
BUT I THINK SHE COULD MODEL
QUITE WELL.
KEENYAH.
SHE LOOKS THE SAME.
YEAH, I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE HER PERSONALITY
COME THROUGH A LITTLE MORE.
KAHLEN.
I FIND HER TO BE STIFF,
BORING, LIKE A FRIGID CHICKEN.
SHE'S NOT POSING.
THERE'S NO THOUGHT PROCESS
WHATSOEVER IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
REBECCA.
REBECCA'S LIKE A BOWL OF
PASTA--KIND OF PLAIN.
SHE NEEDS SOME CHILI PEPPERS.
TIFFANY.
TIFFANY COULD BE
A COUTURE MODEL, BUT SHE JUST
SUCKS WITH HER ATTITUDE.
I THINK SHE WANTS IT
BUT SHE'S SO INTIMIDATED BY IT,
SHE'D RATHER SAY GOOD-BYE TO IT
BEFORE IT SAYS GOOD-BYE TO HER.
SHE'S GOT A LOT TO OFFER,
BUT I THINK SHE DOESN'T BELIEVE
IN HERSELF YET.
MICHELLE.
SOMETHING ABOUT MICHELLE TO ME
IS SO WRONG, BUT, LIKE,
YOU ADD IT UP TOGETHER,
AND IT'S ALMOST RIGHT.
CHRISTINA.
CHRISTINA HAS A MAKEUP FACE.
SHE, LIKE, OTHER GIRLS NEED TO
SNAP OUT OF THIS WEAK SENSE OF--
YEAH, SHE HAS NO UPPER LIP.
I FEEL THE GIRLS TONIGHT
DID HORRIBLY IN GENERAL.
I'M NOT SEEING DRIVE.
I'M LOSING THE HUNGER
IN THE EYES.
THEY HAVE JUST PLATEAUED.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOMETHING
THAT REALLY GETS THE COMPETITION
GOING AGAIN.
THEY NEED A WAKE-UP CALL.
THIS WEEK HAS BEEN
A VERY INTERESTING WEEK
IN THIS JUDGING ROOM.
THE JUDGES ARE
LESS THAN IMPRESSED.
AS A WHOLE,
THE WAY YOU ALL DELIVERED
THE LINES AS A CORRESPONDENT--
THAT'S NOT SOMEONE
THAT'S ON THE WAY TO BEING
A TOP MODEL.
WE'RE NOT LOOKING
FOR PERFECTION, BUT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR SOME PROMISE,
AND WHAT WE SAW TODAY WAS JUST
FLAT-OUT DISAPPOINTING
AND UNINSPIRING.
BUT THERE'S ONE GIRL
THAT WITH HER PHOTO
AND WITH THE WAY
SHE DELIVERED THOSE LINES TODAY,
STOOD OUT,
AND SHE'S SOMEONE THAT YOU GUYS
NEED TO BE WATCHING OUT FOR.
BRITTANY.
I'M PROUD OF YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KEENYAH.
THANK YOU.
NAIMA.
MICHELLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
KAHLEN.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL IS...
CHRISTINA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
OH, GOD.
TATIANA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
WILL TIFFANY AND REBECCA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
THE TWO OF YOU STAND BEFORE ME
FOR TWO VERY DIFFERENT REASONS.
REBECCA, YOU STAND BEFORE ME
ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL,
PROBABLY THE BEST MODEL
HIGH FASHION BODY OF THE BUNCH,
AND I KNOW YOU WANT THIS,
AND I KNOW YOU TRY.
BUT WE FEEL
LIKE YOUR PROGRESS
IS JUST LIKE THIS--JUST SAFE.
TIFFANY, YOU STAND BEFORE ME
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WANTS THIS
MORE THAN YOU.
YOUR GRANDMOTHER WANTS THIS
SO BADLY FOR YOU.
SOMETIMES WHEN OUR LIVES
ARE SO HARD AND SO DIFFICULT,
AND SOMETHING THAT IS
SO FANTASTIC COMES ABOUT,
SOMETIMES WE FEEL LIKE
WE'RE NOT WORTH IT.
AND IF YOU DON'T FEEL
YOU'RE WORTH IT, THEN NONE
OF THESE PEOPLE BEHIND ME
AND I WON'T FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE WORTH IT.
WE THINK MAYBE YOU MIGHT NEED
A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME
TO LOOK IN THAT MIRROR,
FIND SOME SELF-ESTEEM
AND START LOVING YOURSELF.
THIS IS A REALLY
DIFFICULT DECISION TONIGHT.
YOU'VE PUT ME
IN A VERY DIFFICULT PLACE.
TONIGHT...
BOTH OF YOU
WILL PACK YOUR BAGS
AND RETURN TO THE LOFT.
THANK YOU.
CHEER UP. GO AHEAD.
LOOKIN' ALL SAD.
COME ON. COME ON.
GOOD LUCK.
OH, GIRL,
YOU GOTTA STOP.
CAN YOU GUYS
STAND IN FRONT OF ME?
I JUST WANT TO SAY
ONE MORE THING TO YOU.
REBECCA, I ADMIRE YOUR EMOTION
RIGHT NOW.
IT SHOWS TO ME THAT
THIS WAS SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO YOU.
TIFFANY, I'M EXTREMELY
DISAPPOINTED IN YOU.
THIS IS A JOKE TO YOU.
YOU'VE BEEN
THROUGH ANGER MANAGEMENT,
YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH
YOUR GRANDMOTHER
GETTING HER LIGHTS TURNED OFF
TO BUY YOU A SWIMSUIT
FOR THIS COMPETITION,
AND YOU GO OVER THERE
AND YOU JOKE AND YOU LAUGH.
THIS IS SERIOUS TO THESE GIRLS,
AND THIS SHOULD BE
SERIOUS TO YOU.
LOOKS CAN BE DECEIVING.
I'M HURT. I AM.
BUT I CAN'T CHANGE IT, TYRA.
I'VE BEEN--
YES, YOU CAN.
YOU CAN'T CHANGE WHAT?
I'M SICK OF CRYING ABOUT
STUFF THAT I CANNOT CHANGE.
I'M SICK OF
BEING DISAPPOINTED.
I'M SICK OF ALL OF IT. I'M NOT--
YOU AIN'T SICK
OF BEING DISAPPOINTED.
OBVIOUSLY I AM.
NO, YOU'RE NOT.
IF YOU WERE SICK OF
BEING DISAPPOINTED,
YOU WOULD STAND UP
AND YOU WOULD TAKE CONTROL
OF YOUR DESTINY.
DO YOU KNOW THAT YOU HAD
A POSSIBILITY TO WIN?
DO YOU KNOW THAT ALL OF AMERICA
IS ROOTING FOR YOU?
DO YOU KNOW THAT?
AND THEN YOU COME IN HERE
AND YOU TREAT THIS LIKE A JOKE.
YOU COME IN HERE
AND LOOK AT THAT AND SAY,
"I CAN'T READ THAT."
YOU READ TEN TIMES BETTER THAN
HALF OF THOSE GIRLS OVER THERE.
YOU DID.
AND YOU COME IN HERE
WITH A DEFEATIST ATTITUDE.
I DON'T HAVE A BAD ATTITUDE.
MAYBE I AM ANGRY INSIDE.
I'VE BEEN THROUGH STUFF,
SO I'M ANGRY.
YES, BUT THIS IS NOT--
BE QUIET, TIFFANY.
BE QUIET!
WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU?
STOP IT!
I HAVE NEVER IN MY LIFE
YELLED AT A GIRL LIKE THIS!
WHEN MY MOTHER YELLS LIKE THIS,
IT'S BECAUSE SHE LOVES ME!
I WAS ROOTING FOR YOU!
WE WERE ALL
ROOTING FOR YOU!
HOW DARE YOU?!
LEARN SOMETHING FROM THIS!
WHEN YOU GO TO BED AT NIGHT,
YOU LAY THERE AND YOU TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR YOURSELF!
'CAUSE NOBODY'S GONNA TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR YOU.
YOU ROLLIN' YOUR EYES,
AND YOU ACT LIKE THIS 'CAUSE
YOU'VE HEARD IT ALL BEFORE.
YOU'VE HEARD IT
ALL BEFORE.
YOU DON'T KNOW
WHERE THE HELL I COME FROM.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
I'VE BEEN THROUGH.
BUT I'M NOT A VICTIM.
I GROW FROM IT
AND I LEARN.
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR YOURSELF.
I'VE NEVER SEEN TYRA
THAT WAY EVER.
I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE HER
BEING THAT WAY.
BUT SHE'S ANGRY
BECAUSE SHE THINKS
TIFFANY HASN'T CHANGED AND THAT
SHE TAKES THIS AS A JOKE
AND THAT EVERYONE WANTS IT
SO BAD FOR HER,
BUT SHE DOESN'T EVEN WANT IT
FOR HERSELF.
I'M NOT FENNA BREAK DOWN
FOR YOU AND NOBODY ELSE.
YOU AIN'T DID... FOR ME
BUT BRING ME HERE
AND PUT ME THROUGH HELL
THESE WEEKS.
I THINK TYRA MIGHT
BE REALLY RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
TYRA.
SHE WAS RIGHT.
THE ONLY THING
THAT'S KEEPING ME HERE
WAS MY GRANDMA AND MY CHILD.
AND I TRIED TO HANG IN THERE
FOR MY GRANDMA.
MY GRANDMA JUST WANTS
THE BEST FOR ME.
I'M REALLY DISAPPOINTED
RIGHT NOW.
BUT NOT EVERYONE CAN SAY
THEY'VE DONE THIS,
AND I CAN PUT THAT CHECK MARK
NEXT TO IT.
I'M WALKING AWAY HERE
KNOWING A LOT MORE
ABOUT THE BUSINESS
AND ESPECIALLY ABOUT MYSELF
AND WHAT MY PRIORITIES ARE.
FAMILY IS NUMBER ONE.
I'M GOING HOME TO GET MARRIED,
AND WE'LL TAKE IT FROM THERE.
PART OF ME DID GIVE UP.
I WAS BEING VERY DISRESPECTFUL.
BUT I'M TAKING
A LOT HOME WITH ME.
TYRA REALLY DID CARE ABOUT ME--
HER YELLING AT ME.
I HAVE THE UTMOST RESPECT
FOR HER 'CAUSE SHE COULD HAVE
EASILY SAID, "OKAY, WHATEVER"
AND, YOU KNOW, "BYE."
THAT SHOWED ME
THAT SHE SAW DEEPLY INTO ME
AND SHE CARED ABOUT ME.
AND THAT'S COOL KNOWING THAT,
YOU KNOW, TYRA CARES ABOUT YOU.
I'M GOING TO GO BACK HOME
AND HAVE A GOOD LIFE NOW
AND BE THE BEST TIFFANY
I CAN BE.
STAYED TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
SHOCK WAVES FROM JUDGING
PUT THE GIRLS ON EDGE.
THEY ELIMINATED BOTH OF THEM.
IT JUST SHOWS YOU
THAT IT'S ANYONE'S GAME.
THE MODELS GET A TASTE
OF THE SPOTLIGHT.
ANYONE IN THE HOUSE YOU EVER
WANTED TO JUST STRANGLE?
BUT A CELEBRITY GUEST LEAVES
THEM AT A LOSS FOR WORDS.
OH, MY GOD.
AND A PERSONAL TRAGEDY
SHATTERS KAHLEN'S FOCUS.
MY MIND JUST IS BLANK.
SHE'S A GREAT GIRL,
AND I DON'T WANNA SEE HER GO
HOME OVER SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
♪♪♪